je pense que la france aura à choisir
entre la construction d'un camp
républicain ou bien la venue au pouvoir
dans des conditions paris des
conséquences extrêmement dure comment on
n'a pas imaginé depuis peut-être 60 ans
d'un bloc réactionnaire
tout l'enjeu il est là et il va au delà
d'ailleurs de la gauche et de la droite
il va sur l'avenir effectivement de la
france de l'europe et oui quand non
seulement on connaît la position du
front national qui n'est pas de corriger
l'europe et les de sortir de l'europe
bien et je le dis j'ai entendu un
certain nombre de choses joyet par
exemple monsieur wauquiez se prononcer
pour la suppression de la commission
européenne dans un discours avec des
éléments et les propositions
démagogiques qui le met dans une
dynamique qui l'amènera à être aspiré
par la position du front national vous
savez il y aura il y aura pas 36
position il y aura ceux sur l'europe
mais pas simplement sur l'europe il y
aura ceux qui ont une attitude xénophobe
et ceux qui auront une attitude
républicaine
il y aura ceux qui ont une attitude de
construction de l'europe et de
renaissance européenne et ceux qui
seront pour la santé heureux la droite
elle se laisse un peu aspiré par les
positions du fondation we bien sûr je le
dis je le confirme il ya un débat y
compris au sein de la droite et dans la
société française entre des gens qui
dans un monde tout à fait bouleversé où
on voit d'ailleurs les pulsions
populiste le populisme en france à une
cata une caractéristique particulière il
est marqué par la xénophobie et par le
racisme
à la différence de populisme différents
qui peuvent exister ou encore dans
d'autres pays chez nous ce populisme est
à l'oeuvre il est à l'action et il
aspire une partie de la droite pas
simplement de l'extrême